-You have the coolest
microphone thing.
It looks like a tie clasp.
-Yeah, isn't that really -
That's top-level.
-I was thinking like --
That looks pretty sharp.
-What do you guys wear?
Is that what you do at CNN
-Yeah, just this.
-It's like that?
-Yours looks cool,
like it's intended.
-Yeah.
-Well, you have
your own show, too.
You've got to get one of these
-I don't have as much pull
I don't think.
-Yeah. Well, the problem is,
you have a show
on a network
that has too many hosts.
So they'd be like, "You get one,
then Cuomo's going to want one
Anderson's going to want one."
-Exactly.
-You can't do that.
Whereas me, it's --
-It's not just one tie clip.
-I guarantee you,
if I've got it,
that means Fallon had it first
[ Laughter ]
-It does actually
have his initials.
-It does, yeah.
-"J.F. -- do not touch."
Oh, no.
-You hosted the debates.
-I did.
-And that is a lot.
Not only was it
back-to-back nights,
but 10 candidates both nights.
Did you -- How do you approach
it with that many people?
-Well, first of all,
we should just make sure
everybody understands.
If it were up to me, I would
have like five candidates.
But it was the Democratic
National Committee.
They made the decision.
-Right. Not CNN's choice.
-And they said, "This is
what you have to achieve
in order to get on
the debate stage."
And it turns out
it was very achievable.
-Yeah.
-So they had 20 candidates
Thank God we were allowed
to split it into two nights.
And it's tough, because al
these competing imperatives.
You want to make sure that
you get to the big people,
the bigger candidates, but you
also want to include everybody
You want to bring out debate
You want to get to as many
topics as you can,
but you don't want
to be too shallow.
I mean,
it's a lot of moving parts
-It did seem that you guys
got credit for hitting on
a lot of substantive issues.
Obviously, a limit of time
and the fact that 10 peopl
are talking.
And I think when --
We remember the last debat
that had that many candidate
was the GOP debates 4 years ago.
You did those, as well.
-Yea, I did one
with 11 candidates.
-11 candidates at once.
-Because Carly Fiorina
got in there.
-She slid in at the last minute.
-Yeah.
-And thank God she did,
because then she was president
But you -- Those, I think,
are not remembered as bein
as substantive, but you woul
argue that they were.
We just forget because of Trump.
-Because of who was
in the middle of the stage
I think we asked a lot
of substantive questions,
but I think one of the problem
with a debate
anytime that President Trump -
then candidate Trump -- is there
is, you might not remember
the discussion
about the nuclear triad, for
example, which was brought up.
And you might remember whe
he made fun of Rand Paul's hair.
-Yeah.
-One of them might stick out -
stick in your brain
a little bit more.
-Yeah. Do you think that wil
ultimately be the challeng
for whoever ends up against him,
moving forward?
Is that -- As voters,
we will also be distracted
by his ability to make fun o
sort of trivial things?
-I don't know. That's going to
be the big challenge
for whoever
the Democratic nominee is.
What's the way to go after him
Because you could argue
that Hillary Clinton won
all three debates.
-Yeah, I think pretty --
Like, by a clear margin.
-Polls indicated that the
American people thought she did.
-Yeah.
-And then, yet,
she's obviously not
at the White House right now
-Yeah, 'cause they were like
"That other guy
is a little crazy, though.
I kind of like that.
Let's see what that looks like
in the White House.
Let's try the crazy guy.
It's only for a week, right?
Four years?!"
-It was a little bit more
complicated than that.
But okay. We'll go with that
-I think most voters --
Trust me.
I've been in the diners.
That's what they did.
I've talked to people in diners.
So you --
-There were the Russians
and Comey and Wisconsin.
-There's a lot of things.
-A lot of factors.
-You've had this issue,
because you have to deal with it
certainly in a more serious wa
than we do.
There have been things this week
that are hard to lay out
exactly what happened.
Steve King,
who is an Iowa Congressman
he basically made comments
defending rape and incest.
Which you would think
would be a real career ender
but not as yet.
How do you even --
When you hear that,
how do you even go about
presenting that to people
as "here's a real thing
that happened"?
-Well, I mean,
we just ran the clip.
And just for those of you
who are not familiar
With Congressman King's
oeuvre...
-Yeah.
-He says a lot of just reall
insane and offensive things.
-Yeah, the craziest thing is
it wasn't out of left fiel
for him.
-Yeah. The good news was,
it wasn't racist.
-Yeah, that's right.
He tried a new thing.
That's like,
be careful what you wish for
It's like -- Good news.
He's not racist anymore.
-Well, it wasn't that --
Just in those comments he was,
"I'm going to try
a little misogyny.
Let's just see how that goes
Try it on for size."
Yeah, the basic argument
he was making,
he was trying to explain -
he was trying to defend
his argument as to why
he does not support --
he's opposed to abortion
and he does not even believe i
exemptions for rape and incest
And his argument was,
"If you go back in history
you know,
a lot of people got raped
and a lot of people had incest
and I don't know that my famil
tree doesn't have any of that.
-Yeah. I'd argue
it probably does, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It would explain a lot.
-Yeah. It would, yeah.
-But, anyway,
so, in that instance,
we just ran the clip.
And then I just turned
to a guy on the panel,
poor Mike Rogers,
former Republican Congressman,
and just said, "Why does he sa
things like that?"
-Yeah.
-He didn't have an answer.